-You've known Poehler
for a long time.
You met Amy Poehler
back in Chicago.
What was your
first meeting like?
-Well, one of my good friend
named Ragsdale lived with --
-I'm so glad you have
a friend named Ragsdale.
-Ragsdale. And he's just wha
you would think.
Like, Ragsdale gave me my firs
Neil Gaiman comic book.
-Oh, there you go.
That's a classic Ragsdale move
-Ragsdale is like, "You know
you can clean the resin
out of that thing."
And he had all the tips.
-Yeah, yeah.
We all need a Ragsdale.
You're lucky.
You had a sensei and a Ragsdale.
-Totally.
-Yeah.
-Ragsdale lived in a house
with Matt Besser,
one of the founders of
Upright Citizens Brigade.
And, so, Amy and I met
at parties
over there, making mischief.
And we did -- We recognize
one another in a sort of
sibling way of like,
"Hey, you know, like,
you're a class clown,
I'm a class clown."
And she would always
just punch me.
And I was like, "Yeah,
I've been friends with her
for a long time.
She punches me when I see her.
-And then, of course, you --
As we've already mentioned
"Parks and Recreation,"
Ron Swanson.
To finish up here,
how do you think Ron Swanson
would be handling
the coronavirus panic?
-I don't think he would
necessarily notice.
But if he did, I mean,
Leslie would probably send him
a missive or
some sort of message.
And he would just take his
family to one of his cabin
in the woods,
where he was heading anyway,
and they would just
enjoy, you know, some fishin
and some items from his garden
until things blew over.
-Yeah, I think we should
all be so lucky
to have Ron Swanson's
self-preservation.
-Yeah, when the [bleep]
goes down, Ron is all set up
-Yeah, absolutely.
Always a pleasure
to see you, my friend.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you so much.
-Nick Offerman.